what is the image of the polygon below
after the rotation so this is a
transformation it's a rotational
transformation of 270 degrees
so what we and when they talk about a
rotational transformation at least in
the context of this exercise we're
talking about a rotation around the
origin so around this point so the way i
like to think about it is pick one of
these points one of these orange points
and essentially rotate it around the
origin 270 degrees so let's do that so
this would be rotating it and and when
we talk about positive angles we're
talking about going in the
counterclockwise directions the same way
that we typically measure angles when
we're doing trigonometry with the unit
circle and things like that so here so
we started here and let's rotate 90
degrees
then we could keep rotating rotate
another 90 degrees so we've rotated a
total of 180 degrees and then we rotate
90 more degrees to get to 270.
let's do a couple more of these
what is the transformation that rotates
the blue s the blue solid shape to the
orange dashed shape now this one's a
little bit we don't have we don't have
the manipulative here to help us answer
that question so this is really going to
challenge
challenge our powers of visualization so
the main thing is to pick a point on the
blue shape and see where does it end up
on the orange dash shape
and i'll pick this point right over here
because you can see it's kind of
pointing straight in that it's pointing
straight to the top left and then when
you go onto the orange dash shape it's
pointing to the bottom right so this one
went all the way around so you could say
it went it was pointing from this
direction and went all the way to going
in the exact opposite direction and this
so this was a 180 degree transformation
180 degree
rotation
let's do
a few more
so what's the image of the polygon so
they want to do another 270 degree
rotation so like before so let's rotate
let's rotate this
three-fourths of the way around so let's
see how we can do that so right now
so this is going to be a little bit
trickier so if we actually i'm going to
pick this point because it's easier to
visualize the 270 degrees so
now we've done 90 degrees
now we can do 180 degrees and now we've
done
200
and
degrees